this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists
fewer obligations that sounds like a
solid
new year's resolution um
yeah or maybe let's get specific here
today we're going to talk about reducing
maybe maybe even eliminating
obligations if you're watching this on
youtube you'll probably see that we are
in a
new studio space it's a temporary studio
space
let us know what you think in the
comments of this space who knows we
might record more
in this space we've got a few other
spaces we're testing out
and before we move into our new studio
and
this may be one of them that you see
recurring on our
youtube channel by the way youtube.com
the minimalists
now ryan we're we're less than a month
into the or so we're less than a week
into
no we're less than a month into the year
right
and it's what 12 days actually into
the year we did a new year's resolutions
episode and i got to tell you i don't
even remember what i said my new year's
resolution
was did we have a guess for that no it
was just me and you oh yeah
this is last week's episode now of
course the the the
maximal version is where we revealed our
own new year's resolutions
now here's the thing i don't know what
my new year's resolution is
i i've always said i think they're a bit
hokey uh
they're chasing etc now
i do have a word though and so i heard
erwin mcmanus who um i heard him talking
about this
about instead of having a new year's
resolution he has a word
for 2021 like what is his word in my uh
so i'm part of this men's team and they
would call it your context
ooh and what they there's a training
that they do
where it's called cpr context purpose
results
so you've got your context you've got
the purpose behind that context and then
you have the results that you want but
context is so powerful
and it's usually one or two words
because when you find yourself
losing your context or losing maybe
control or feeling off
you can go back to those one or two
words and be like i gotta hold this
context this is what i want to hold
right now so do you have a context you
have a word or a phrase for 2021
uh i think my phrase would be if i did i
haven't thought about this on the spot i
would say
love people because the opposite never
works thanks for listening y'all will
see it next time
um no but my context would be keep going
um yeah there's probably a stronger
context i could come up with but
as soon as you said that that's the
first thing that came to my mind where
it was like
because i would love to say that oh
now that you know 1201 am
hit on january 1 and now it's 2021 we
can put 2020 behind us and have a good
this is going to be my year right you
know um
but man time doesn't care
right about your about uh you know the
problems that you're in i mean yeah
enough time and they you know
things go away but but we're still in
the thick of a lot of
of uh discomfort inconvenience
um anxiety you know whatever word you
want to put in there
so for me i don't want to just have this
attitude of like well it's 20 21 it's a
new year it's gonna be a good year like
i know that we're in for it still right
so that context of keep going
is really important to me because um i
do see myself as a resilient person but
dude it's wearing me down i'm not gonna
lie man yeah we've got a lot to talk
about
and i think a lot of that wearing down
has to do with obligations or perceived
obligations
my word for this year by the way is
healing we can talk about that
uh at a later date and but uh in order
to get to that healing
i can see an untethering from
obligations so ryan on twitter we had a
question from eve the redhead i thought
it would be the perfect question to
start this episode
when is an obligation an actual
obligation
and not a perceived obligation
let me say this ryan hmm they're
at the end of the day under the the
surface when we peel back the layers
the truth behind the truth is
they're all perceived obligations there
is no
real obligation yeah it all
it all requires what the mind yeah
and and so there every obligation is a
product of the mind oh i love that
so really obligation is something well a
humans invented that word and we've
thrust it upon ourselves
right to make us feel obligated right
when
yeah i love that but there really is
there's no such thing as an obligation
let me ask you is commitment synonymous
with obligation can that mean the same
thing i think they can be if you had a
venn diagram with commitment
and obligation they're going to overlap
there's going to be quite a bit of
overlap
there now i think in this that that
section where they do overlap especially
you start to realize it exposes one of
the flaws
of obligation because obligation and
especially commitment they sound like
good things right i'm an obligated you
know committed person right
and even morally good virtuous in a way
right yeah
but commitment the only time
we need commitment is when we don't have
the desire to do something
the only time we need commitment is when
we don't have
the desire to do something and so i
would say the same thing about
obligation
so that commitment basically pushes us
into well i committed to it so i'm going
to do it
sort of yeah yeah i think so now now
what i'm saying here in addition to that
is the thing one of the things you're
most passionate about
is snowboarding sure and now imagine
you're at the top of
you know the black diamond at wherever
discovery
yeah and which was in montana and you're
you're picturing it right now right yeah
do you have to commit to going down the
hill no
of course not you have you just do it
because you have
the deep desire to do it and that's the
same thing with these resolutions the
reason resolutions don't work
has nothing to do with the resolution
it's because we don't have the deep
desire
there's a difference between wanting
something one thing is kind of like
oh hey ryan do you want a million
dollars oh sure would be nice if that
was in my bank account
sure and a deep desire
to earn a million if you had the deep
desire to earn a million dollars you you
would go do it now
you would do a bunch of things that
maybe not aren't congruent with you and
that's the reason you
aren't a millionaire right now we'll
just turn on ads man yeah we could yeah
that'd be the best way to do is start
doing advertisements on the podcast that
we could do
uh instead of being patreon supported
because i think of what is it
uh sean i think it's fewer than five
percent of our audience actually
supports
our podcast and gets the maximum
episodes by the way all the good
stuff quote unquote good stuff is is on
the maximal episodes and they're you
know it's what twice as long as this and
and it's a much deeper dive but
most people don't support and that's not
good or bad
either you you get an opportunity to
listen to this so so
just for this commitment conversation
you're not saying commitment is good or
bad you're just talking about
commitment in general commitment yes
you're correct
commitment seems good and that is a
problem
because we think of commitment as good
the problem is
you turn that word commitment into
obligation and you begin to
obligate yourself to everything and it
makes us
miserable and i have a hypothesis a
theory
really that all obligations reduce our
tranquility
in some way yeah bex came to me this
morning
and she was i had some bit of news about
uh vaccines or something
and and i just stopped and i said hey
bex um
this is not serving my well-being this
conversation is not and she was and it
is
because she's so understanding and
appreciates my own well she wants
my well-being uh to increase and
and so i found that one that one
observation hey this isn't increasing my
my well-being or
or bringing me tranquility in some way
and i wanted to
read this real quick ryan this essay is
not out yet this is something sean just
edited for me
uh it's called confined by attachment
and i think it touches on this whole
tranquility
obligation piece here and we can we can
expand on that
by the way you you'll get this in your
email box if you're on our email list
over at the minimalists.com we'll never
send you
spam or advertisements or junk here is
confined by
attachment a very short essay certainly
some attachments are healthy
our attachments to family and friends
to community and customs and charity
those are appropriate attachments right
let's consider that question from a
different angle replace the word
attachments
with clinging that small change
exposes the flaw in quote healthy
attachments certainly some clinging
is healthy right no be it possessions or
people or pride
clinging is never healthy
every attachment is a tether that
restricts our freedom
a governor that constricts our ability
to love we can't live right
now if we're fastened to the future
and we can't love fully when we're
confined
by attachment we've been told by pop
music and poetry
that to need someone
is to love them but that was a lie
that's not love it's clinging
we experience the full spectrum of love
only
when we let go let go of the attachment
not the person without the clinging
all that remains is love hmm
i think i might replace that word
clinging in in this context
with what we're talking about with
obligations here yeah let's see that
aren't obligations often
maybe not always but aren't they often
at least a type of clinging oh i feel
obligated to do that yeah and it really
makes me question like what are we
clinging on to
oh yeah expand on that well you know
like
you've got an obligation let's say i
have an obligation i feel like i have an
obligation to
oh i don't something to do with mariah i
don't know insert example there
so the obligation is something
i would take on for a very valiant
effort to be like well you know she's my
partner she's my wife i love her
i'm going to do this for her because it
makes her happy um
but if it is causing me misery
yes i'm just and i don't have an answer
but it makes me question like what
am i clinging to for that
you know for the misery yeah i don't
know i don't really know how to
explain i think this is great let me try
to explain a little bit of what i'm
hearing
and you tell me what you think anthony
demelo who on the maximal episode today
we're going to be reading from one of
his books
his last book actually the right before
he died the way to love
but he has a phenomenal book called
awareness
from which i've read a little bit of an
excerpt on the election podcast
we could have made love people use
things like 100 100 book
yeah by the way we wrote them all that
small this this this book is so
profound i mean it's it's i i can't even
explain it anyway
anthony demelo has an exercise he says
you don't you don't really want to be
happy
and he's talking about you in this
context specifically
and he's like i can prove it to you
watch um go up to the person you love
the most and say i would rather be happy
than to have you
yeah yeah and and if that were the
choice
what would you choose now
the opposite is also true right
what if mariah came to you and said
i now you're highly evolved so you i
know what your answer would be to this
but most people would say
if their spouse came and said hey it's
either if i'm in this
relationship i'm unhappy yeah or
i can be happy without you
a lot of us would say well i'd rather
you be unhappy with me
yeah yeah that's interesting
yeah i wonder and even then there's
there's like a clinging there too right
where someone would rather rather their
mate be unhappy with them
yeah and by the way so i would rather
both of us be unhappy together
than to be happy apart yeah right and
and so we're going to be exploring that
today i think that has a lot to do
with obligations we're going to start
with some questions here we
have a question from i'm sorry before we
go to the questions
can we talk a little bit more about
commitment because
you brought up the snowboarding incident
and there are times when i'm going down
that black diamond
where i have to commit and what i mean
by that is i will have to commit to a
certain turn
i'll have to commit to a certain cut
i'll have to commit to a certain landing
if i'm you know hitting a little jump or
something
sure and it's so uncomfortable but like
what i had and
i'm just trying to again talk about this
work commitment
but i have learned um perfect example
i talked about my mountain biking thing
where i went down that
15-foot cliff on accident like straight
down and
what i told myself is i was like okay uh
i'm probably gonna get hurt doing this
falling down this cliff but i know that
i have to commit
to holding on to these handlebars i have
to put my butt in the seat lean
you know lean back as far as i can plant
my feet and i gotta commit to that
because that's my best
opportunity to not get harmed and i did
i landed all i did was like pop
my tire um i did have kind of a big
bruise on my leg from
something scraping it i think it
happened so fast i don't even know what
it was right
but it was because of that uncomfortable
committing in the moment that really
helped me to not get seriously injured
yeah so i guess
um i don't know i i don't know i just
had that thought
what do you think about commitment when
it comes to that and i'm not trying to
do an opt-out thing i'm just i'm just
trying to no
i think i think that's what you mean by
commitment that's not what i
mean by commitment right and and so uh
if what you mean by commitment is is
following through yeah then with an
action
to get the preferred outcome yeah while
you're in the middle of the action by
the way everything you're talking about
here is not committing to something it's
taking an action in the moment yeah and
it's also
not on that venn diagram it wouldn't
intersect with obligation there
no yeah no and so commitment
is i'm going to do this
despite wanting not wanting to do it in
order to get a result
when you were up in the air it wasn't
that well i don't want to grab the
handlebars now it wasn't that you didn't
want to
do it it did not require a commitment by
the way that required
instinct and a desire to live yeah
but but that the the reason i thought
the snowboarding example was a much
better
example here is same thing it's not
requiring commitment there's a
deep desire for you to do it as soon as
you have a deep desire to do anything
be with a person write a book run a
marathon
swim for the first time learn how to
ride a bicycle
as soon as you have that desire remember
you learned to ride a bicycle as a kid
oh my god dude i did it on my own with a
bike that was way too big
wow and uh yeah but but but you're right
though like i had that desire so much
that it didn't feel like a commitment as
much as like i had to do it
you never committed to do to riding a
bike you simply
said i have this design i'm going to do
this there was there wasn't you didn't
even require language around it
it simply required and by the way it
didn't require action steps there
weren't seven steps to ride a bike
it wasn't how to ride a bike
it was i have this deep desire the
problem is
i don't know how to ride a bike the only
solution
isn't a solution the solution is the
desire
to learn to understand to
eradicate the obstacles there's
something here with that venn diagram
when commitment intersects with
obligation
it ruins it i don't i mean i'm just i'm
not
playing planting my flag in that
statement but i'm positing that
when commitment intercepts intersects
with obligation
um it's a good recipe for discontent yes
indeed
we got let's talk a lot more about that
we do have some questions here let's
start with alexis
in portland oregon i have type 1
diabetes also known as juvenile diabetes
and i'm lucky to work for a company that
makes a product for type 1 diabetes and
it's a product i actually
use as well and it's really changed my
life probably saved my life a couple
times too
so i'm super aligned with the values and
the goals and the vision of my company
and my co-workers my co-workers are all
awesome people who
have a passion about diabetes that we
all share
so i find everybody to be very
supportive i'm lucky to align with those
core values
my company is also awesome because a lot
of us volunteer at local diabetes events
and we get to go there together and make
an impact in the community
where i struggle is when we go to
charity events together
and everybody is donating money to
diabetes causes and i want to be able to
support this
as much as humanly possible because hey
it benefits me
benefits my tribe and i really support
donating to diabetes organizations
i don't have a lot of disposable income
right now and some of my co-workers do
and the ones that don't even say things
like well hey
it's for a charity so i'll put it on my
credit card if i have to
so when the time comes to give and i
don't have very much money to give i
know i shouldn't feel bad about it
because it doesn't fit within my budget
and i have to live within that budget
not them but it's hard because it's
something i truly believe in
and there is unfortunately a little bit
of that social pressure around it as
well
how can i reconcile my budget with
wanting to give back to
an amazing cause alexis i don't have any
advice for you but i have
some observations so
first off i know that if i don't have
money and
so let's take the terminus ryan let's
look at
i don't have a million dollars in cash
right and if you do
could i have something i don't have a
million dollars in cash but let's say
i know of a really good cause the
against malaria foundation is the most
effective charity in the world
and a million dollars would actually
save a lot of
lives it would be the best use of a
charitable use of a million dollars
that you can quantify at least and so
the against malaria foundation
so over my lifetime i could probably pay
back a million dollars
why don't i just go into debt for a
million dollars
to save people's lives yeah now
the reason that we give to charity is
what we think that it's altruistic but
it's
never and i with there are a few savants
a few mozarts of living where this they
would be the exception
but they're all opt-out clauses yeah
there are some yeah exactly
but but for us mere mortals yes uh
there is never a time that we give
completely altruistically the self is
never removed there's always a little
good feeling of like oh i gave today
yes oh man i i'm so glad i could sit
here and feel like a good person
or or even worse than that this is where
alexis is
i just don't want to feel like a bad
person oh yeah
which is that by the way we think we're
chasing happiness no we're not we're not
chasing happiness
we're merely running away from pleasure
oh i'm sorry running away from pain from
pain from misery let's just
use the actual word misery right so it's
not just pain
we're running away from misery so
if i were to say that again and say it
accurately we're never running toward
happiness
we were always running from
misery yeah and so that's where i hear
the misery in alex's voice right
so we can agree that it's not an
appropriate
let's take good or bad out of it for a
moment we'll talk about that it's not an
appropriate decision to go into
debt to make yourself which makes you
going to make you miserable it's going
to restrict your freedom
in order to contribute to a charity yeah
it's interesting it's like uh
and maybe we'll go into the good or bad
thing but
giving to charity good going into debt
for it bad so it's like you're
alleviating
you're kind of canceling it out i like
what you're saying here because well you
know i mean i don't agree with it but i
like what you're saying yeah yeah so
with um with uh yeah and i'm talking
about perceived good and bad but we can
expand on that a little bit but alexis i
know
your co-workers actually have really
good intentions
i'm not justifying you know them kind of
putting pressure
on her but their intentions are good and
maybe they are trying to like push you a
little bit towards
donating and they're trying to actually
make you have this
feeling of where you're struggling like
well maybe i should put it on a credit
card
but ultimately the best way that you can
take care of someone else
is when you yourself are fully taken
care of yes
and if you are putting yourself in debt
to take care of
someone else that's actually going to
hurt you in the long run the short term
maybe it's a good solution
you could not judge yourself so harshly
which i would just posit don't judge
yourself
yourself at all uh if you can look in
the mirror and saying that you're doing
the best for you
then then you know there's no reason um
i think for
hurting for alexis to judge yourself
here but again
doing something that hurts you in the
long run
for a short term uh thing that you see
as positive in your life i
don't yeah personally like that's not
what i would do i'm not
trying to prescribe anything here but
but yeah you got to take care of
yourself alexis before you can
fully 100 help other people so maybe
that
maybe that's where she can go instead of
like beating herself up for not
giving to charity and going into debt
for for giving to charity
maybe she can focus on like hey i'm
taking care of me right now so
ultimately i'm gonna be able to give
beyond myself in a meaningful way
once i have my house in order i agree
with that and i also think that
when you are giving beyond yourself in a
meaningful way you're still
taking care of yourself in a way because
the more
you give the more you grow the more you
grow the more you have to give at least
theoretically
that's the way that it works i'm trying
to look at this because her problem is
like there's these
societal obligations she feels obligated
to contribute
and she feels bad if she doesn't
contribute let me just say this
contributing to charity is not good
now i know that right right away it's
going to turn a lot of people off
what do you mean it's not good yeah it's
also not bad it's also not
bad yes um it is
well you just stop there it is that's
beautiful
we're gonna talk on the maxwell episode
about help because i believe that
all help is a result of the ego here's
an
here is a quick snippet for you ryan i'm
just going to read this
really quick this essay is not out yet
sean hasn't even looked at it
it is called the advice epidemic
and this line i think will stand out to
you
there is no bigger ego than that of the
helper
the helpful man simply cannot help
himself
he feels obligated to tear an eagle from
the sky
to save him from falling to drag a
dolphin to the shore to rescue her from
drowning
we want to help a lot and we think it's
even virtuous
right to guide to coach
to instruct others it's noble right
noble is ryan's middle name i mean
literally it actually is it is
middle name and this is one of the
biggest things i've changed my mind
about recently ryan is about our need to
help
other people and i think that it's not
good or bad
right but i do think that it is a little
bit dangerous
and i think that it the desire to just
be helpful isn't necessarily loving
so what just with that thought because
we've
we've been talking a lot about
these value judgments and
what and what we've i feel like what
we've been saying since we've been
having these conversations is these
things that are good they're not good
they're not bad but they're not they
just are
but you use the word virtuous so what is
virtuous
um yeah so what does virtue mean right
well yeah but i'm saying like what act
is a virtuous act
right in order to get there we have to
we have to figure out what does virtuous
mean right
and so virtue means from a position of
strength
right i'm sure there are alternate
definitions there but but
when we're talking about someone being
virtuous
it means they're approaching something
from a position of
strength right yeah i don't have a
dictionary on me
um so why is virtuous
associated with uh
being a good person you're exposing my
second question for
alexis so the good or bad thing we'll
set that aside for a moment
uh the second problem beneath the
problem
for alexis is the word she used tribe
so now you know me i will say that
tribes unite against
something community unites around
something however i think both of those
can be
a problem for us why because they
what happens when we have a group of
people well you start to
you know as as inclusive as that group
is it eventually becomes
exclusive that's true and also if you're
included in that group
right you adopt their methods their
their culture basically yeah it becomes
your society
in a way right and i think society writ
large
and then culture in general are one of
the biggest problems
not only do they encourage mediocrity
but they encourage
all of these all of the nonsense that we
experience the anxiety that you're
experiencing
is only a product of the mind
but that mind that is influenced by
culture without culture you're not going
to feel anxiety
and so the pressure that you're feeling
alexis is internal for sure but
also is a result of the acculturation of
your tribe
because it feels good we're we're really
we're chasing the pleasure there the
feeling good of helping other people so
we could replace good with pleasurable
yes yeah yeah yeah and so
alexis if i really want to get to the
root of your problem i'm going to look
at the problem behind the problem
and that is i'm going to look at
the tribe of which i'm a part and maybe
all of their ideals while it seems
virtuous
are actually affecting you negatively
and you can
give without a tribe
and so so keep that in mind and then
that's not advice that's just stating
a fact um and and then in terms of the
good or bad thing
let's just realize that we're giving
ourselves we're putting so much pressure
on ourselves because we
think that charity is good there is no
good or bad here there is only there's
only truth
and the truth is let's talk about what
is the truth you're exploring
if you have the money to donate to this
charity
some people's lives might be saved right
and that's that in and of itself
sounds virtuous right but everything
else that you tether to it
the the meaning the the the
anxiety the pressure the nervousness
uh those things create misery
interesting we got more to talk about
let's answer a question from amanda in
waco
i wanted to ask a question about debt
repayment and while i'm aware that no
debt is good debt i have medical school
loans that were necessary at the time
to get me to where i am today in
addition my husband and i have a small
zero percent interest credit card
balance
one car payment and what we consider a
modest mortgage
i wanted to get your thoughts on which
debts to tackle first
i think i'm in favor of dave ramsey's
snowball method
of going after the smaller debt first
but value your opinions on the subject
as well
so ryan when we're talking to amanda
here of course you and i we are
dave ramsey disciples i don't there's no
way i could come up with the
the better how to than the seven baby
steps
and i think how to's can be really
effective
when it's for a mechanical thing like
that an elementary sort of thing
and so yes how to's work really well
there
however how to isn't going to continue
to keep you
out of debt once you're out of debt the
lies that you have been telling yourself
i heard several lies now they're not
lies
you're not telling me lies amanda
because what you are saying you believe
to be factual
they're only lies because you continue
to believe them
and so here here's here are two lies i i
heard right
i had to go into debt because it was
necessary at the time
yeah right well okay can you find an
example of a doctor who didn't go into
debt
absolutely of course you can what she's
saying is it was the path of least
resistance for me to do
what i really felt like i had a calling
right yeah but she didn't say that she
lied to herself and said i had to do it
as soon as we back back ourselves into a
corner that becomes
a problem and then i hear these tiny
lies like the white lies of
well we have this zero percent interest
credit card
right oh yeah and it's like oh okay yeah
like so it's it's better now and now
it's good debt now all of a sudden right
these little justifying statements
yes oh we just have you said we have one
car
payment as opposed to what 30 car
payments by the way amanda this is not
judgment on you no
it's just this is speaking the truth
this is loving you
yeah and and i know ryan and i um
we you know obviously we we're out of
debt we've been out of debt
since our early 30s we'll never go back
into debt we'll never advocate for
debt uh and now uh it doesn't mean
that we're recommending that for you you
do whatever you feel is appropriate for
you
and and so if i'm in amanda's shoes yes
of course
i'm going to use the the baby steps
total money makeover all that
uh but i'm also going to examine
let's even call them lies right i'm
going to examine the narrative i've
created
right the narrative of debt was
necessary
right the zero percent thing the one car
payment whatever it is let me examine
that narrative
so that i don't go back into debt in the
future when i heard this question
it just made me think which we've talked
about before on the website and on
podcasts
if you have credit card debt and you're
spending money
outside of attacking that credit card
that you're spending money that you
don't have now i understand you got to
pay your bills you got to buy food
you got to keep a roof over your head
but every
every movie you go to every
non-essential or even worse all the junk
that you're spending money on when you
have credit card debt you're spending
money that you don't have right
so uh yeah i i mean to answer her
question head-on yeah do the snowball
like that's
i wish i would have i did like the
reverse snowball i went
big debts to little debts yeah and um
didn't find out about dave ramsey until
after
i did that uh i wish i would have gone
the other way
yeah yeah because my you know the the
side of me was like well i'm gonna take
care of these big things first
once i take care of the big thing
that'll it'll be out of the way and then
i'll be able to go to the next big thing
and i'll have some momentum
but um it well the you know the packing
party is kind of an example of that
where i just like
did the big huge thing right um but
bring up a great point about so
so it's less about the how to the how to
you you have works in fact ryan you have
a
we have together we have a free ebook on
our website it's uh the minimalists.com
budget it's a ebook called financial
freedom and it's the the steps that you
and i took to get out of debt
and it's slightly different from dave
ramsey but
what i'll say is those are just two
how-to sort of methods
but if you have a deep desire to get out
of debt you're gonna figure it out yeah
and that's what that's really kind of my
answer for amanda is like it doesn't
matter how you do it amanda get out of
debt
yeah josh and i don't care how you do it
what we care is
that you actually get out of debt so uh
i would encourage you to download
that actually i don't want to encourage
you do anything if you want to download
it
uh it's the minimalists.com budget it's
a free ebook called financial freedom
and sean i forgot to do this for alexa
or alexis earlier
we're going to talk more about charity
because i know ryan didn't want
to uh well i didn't want to end it on
charity is not good
no well here's the thing you're right
and so let's just say that
charity uh is not
good or bad contribution yeah well well
the statement i met
made was i don't want to discourage our
listeners from contributing
and then you ask the question of why
right so that's what we'll get to
yeah in fact you made another statement
you said um
i want to encourage people to contribute
and that's my why
yeah i agree with you i do not want to
discourage people from contributing ryan
you and i
have done so much contribution over the
last decade i would
not take back any of it neither would i
um
uh except for the gold teeth that i
bought you
no way dude i'm keeping those it was a
good write-off at least oh man hey
jordan can you like
photoshop some gold teeth on me right
now no
so um what i'm saying though
we've we built a elementary school in
laos we funded a
school in kenya we helped build a
grocery store in dayton ohio
we helped the victims of the orlando
pulse nightclub shooting in the
las vegas shooting we've done so many
things to contribute now
has it helped some people fine what
about yeah hold on
sorry no you're good has it helped some
people
fine that's not my business
yeah it's funny because we are in the we
are ostensibly in in the business of
helping but i love this
uh i love this conversation and kind of
these realizations that that you're
coming to and
we can talk these out on the podcast but
it just made me think though instead of
helping
it's like i want peace okay
yes i want peace i want peace so in
order for me to be peaceful
i have to do certain things and also uh
when when other people are more peaceful
around me that creates more peace
so maybe it's not a matter of helping as
much as
i am living the truth of creating peace
for myself
and also encouraging people to live
their truth which
that's what people want right now anyway
or they've always wanted it in peace
yeah we'll talk more about that for sure
let's send alexis a copy of our first
book
sean minimalism live a meaningful life
there's an entire contribution
chapter in there that you would rewrite
at this point well right and in fact
i i would rewrite everything that i've
done over the last 39 years but i'm not
going to i'm not going to erase the pass
in order to start over
uh and we'll cover that as well but ryan
check your watch what time is it oh dude
it is time for the lightning round where
we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
those texts go to both of our phones
right i know you've been responding to a
lot of them
recently anything really sticking out
are there any emojis that you're seeing
come in no emojis just a lot of awesome
a lot of yeah just a lot of awesome i
want to say compliments but
it's it's encouragement it's gratitude
and
uh makes me feel real good and virtuous
whenever i read those things
no i'm sorry no no it just it really um
it is really heartwarming just to see
the appreciation because
it really does feel like a community
yeah and
i i i do enjoy that feeling of i love
that feeling
of having like a tight community where
where we're all supporting one another
and striving for peace and we're getting
there together
um there are some funny like well
because you know for every thousand
good or you know positive comments
there's like one
you know naysayer yes and it's funny man
because
oh it's it's just it's been really good
because i can handle it really well
and to the point where i can kind of
laugh at some of the criticisms and
stuff
but it's funny because like whenever i
get whenever i receive and i don't know
when this
switch flipped for me i think within
like the last six months man but
when someone gives me criticism like i
can actually look at it
and and ask is this for me yes
and if it is for me i can be like oh let
me examine that
let me dig a little bit deeper at the
problem that this criticism is bringing
up
or i can look at it and be like this
criticism is it's for them it's not for
me
oh yeah but to emotionally connect with
that is a game changer man
or it's about them often as well oh yeah
where if someone were to
send you a text ryan i say in fact go
ahead and text him
uh today if you'd like 937-202-4654 send
him a text and say
ryan you are a chair no i'm not
right i'm not a chair but if for
whatever reason like you know that
that's not true
yeah but what if they had a youtube
video proving
that it was a chair so you know that
you're not a chair but
when the reason sometimes it stings is
someone says
ryan you're not um you know whatever
you're not really you're not toothsome
yeah there you go and you're like ah you
know there's a piece of me that i
thought i was handsome but i'm not
and so like um those things sort of
if you know it's not true it's not going
to bother you at all
yeah yeah yeah exactly you look at it
and you say oh like they're calling me a
chair
that's that's for them yes that's not
for me
right right there's nothing i can do so
you can text ryan tell him he's a chair
or you can uh just text us a picture of
the most recent thing you've decluttered
people have been doing that a lot and
i'm really interested to see
what are the what are the what's the
craziest thing you've decluttered
recently send us a picture of that
yeah pg-13 please yeah um
yeah i haven't had anything uh i haven't
had anything over pg so
that was that's really good um i do want
to share
one criticism that i laughed at
because it actually was a compliment but
they were yeah but
they basically said something like watch
the new documentary
if it wasn't for matt diavela it would
have been a dumpster fire of a
documentary
yeah you imagine me and ryan running
around with cameras right right exactly
oh we're just
doing like yeah selfies with giving a
talk
yeah but it was it was just funny i
started laughing because i'm like well i
would
have no doubt right yeah without matt
without chris newhart without
um jacob jacob matthew with without um
uh uh tim frazier without lauren with i
mean there's so many people you could
say that like
without uh jordan no more podcast sean
without all of them it would be a
dumpster fire imagine me and you
just making a documentary i mean the two
of us could it would take
i don't know decades but we don't have
you know what we don't have that deep
desire
you and i could make a commitment to
making a documentary on our own
and it'd be a real obligation right but
of course
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be what
jordan does with filmmaking because he
has a deep desire
right i have the deepest desire to write
and and thus i
got up at three this morning and wrote
and so
it's not that you should do that or even
that i should do that there is no should
here
should we get to nick's question here
let's do it nick bell has a question for
us pun intended
how do i step back from obligations i've
always
done in the past i struggle to change
when i've said yes many times before and
it's become an assumption
now during the lightning round for those
of you who are new this is where ryan
and i do our best to answer questions
for the short shareable less than 140
character response
you can put the text of those minimal
maxims in the show notes so we can
people can copy and share your pithy
answers or our pithy answers on
on social media and all of our minimal
maximums are in one place now minimal
maxims.com thanks jess nick let me say
this here's my pithy answer for you
maybe we can expand on it maybe we won't
i have two pithy answers for you because
i'm
i'm twice as pithy minimalist
change happens not from how often we say
yes
but when we say yes to only that which
propels us toward our destination
there's a lie we've been told ryan it's
not about the destination man it's about
the journey well that's nonsense
like well yeah yeah keep going without
with no you're good let's talk about it
without without the destination there
would be no journey
that is correct but the yeah so the the
the the destination plays a role right
they both play a role
in both play role yes and so by the way
you didn't go on a journey this morning
when you drove to the studio right
you had a destination in mind and then
the journey resulted because there was a
a destination
right there right here's my other pithy
answer for you you can copy and share
this if you'd like
no is the most freeing word in the world
it is often the most compassionate too
hmm
honest i think we don't realize ryan
that sometimes
we say yes because we're afraid
of saying no but that's not being
compassionate if you're doing something
for someone that you don't want to do
that's not
compassion yeah that is um
that is cowardice and we've all
experienced it i know i've done it a
million times over and i'm sorry a
million times for that it's funny how we
talk ourselves
into doing things that make us miserable
for the sake of virtue
going back to that word yes um
but if you're doing something just for
the sake of being virtuous then
it's kind of not virtuous right exactly
it was i think it was lal zoo
who said the most uh
like all virtue was not virtuous he has
some quote like that
um and and really what he's saying is
we're doing something
to if we're doing something to be
virtuous it's not virtuous
it's not virtuous right yeah and that's
okay too i've got
one and a half pithy answers all right
uh the answer i wrote down for this uh
is boulders can be set down as easily as
they
were picked up and it's funny because i
sent milburn this
um spoiler alert i send him everything i
write for him to edit and shape
so i do that to sean right right i'm
your sean
yeah so uh milburn responded back and he
said well
maybe it would be a little bit punchier
or more powerful if
it's easier to set down than a boulder
down than it is to pick it up
yes and i was like well actually if
anything i would think it's the opposite
well let's think about it in real life
there's a boulder in that corner much
yes yeah and really yeah yeah physically
yes obviously gravity is going to be
much easier going down than up
but these metaphorical boulders it's
difficult to pick
up because they are burdens they're
obligations they are things that
uh if we don't do then we're gonna we're
gonna not feel virtuous
so it's very hard to pick up that
boulder and to follow through with
carrying it but then to put it down
it's equally as hard yes because we are
we feel like we're letting someone else
down we're feeling like we're not being
virtuous if we put that
boulder down so that's why
to me it might even be harder sometimes
to say no but the only way you get good
at it is by
practicing right um the other pithy
answer i have that i thought of
uh had that had that men's group meeting
last night men's team meeting last night
and someone said you cannot prioritize
your commitments there's no such thing
as prioritizing your commitments
and that's for me it rings true here
because either you're committed or
you're not you can't see
you can't have a list of ten commitments
and be like well here are the important
ones like if you've committed you've
committed yeah and so maybe another way
to say that is you can't prioritize your
desires right
because if you have a deep desire to do
something it's either greater than your
desire to do this
like if you want to play you beau
jackson played what football and
baseball right
yes and and and so like if
you have a if you could only choose one
baseball
a lot of people are this way right were
they they were two sport athletes
and they had to choose one well it's
whatever the greater desire was
it wasn't a checklist of commitments and
pros and cons and those things can be
helpful for the most mechanical level
but they can't help us understand our
desire
right let me add an additional uh
minimal maximum for you ryan this is
because i like what you said about the
boulder
and so maybe what was my answer that you
it's easier to set down a boulder than
it is to pick it up
literally quite literally it is yeah
yeah right literally but so maybe
instead of pick it up we
we say carry it forever
it is easier to set down a boulder than
it is to carry it forever you can tweet
that podcast
that's good well ryan we have so much
more to talk about we have a bunch of
listener tips
in this episode today we have an added
value segment which you all
will love but it looks like we got a
bunch more surprise questions this week
as well like
what were the negative side effects of
releasing your new documentary
less is now on netflix um
is it healthy to avoid all praise
man that that seems counterintuitive i
want praise
right how do i permanently say no
at work without risking my job how do i
reduce familial obligations that are
unnecessary and of no value plus
ryan we're going to discuss the advice
epidemic we're going to talk about the
ego
we're going to talk about helping we're
going to talk about why we needn't
convince
anyone of anything we're going to talk
about
finding a mute button for negative
self-talk
and we're going to talk about what
obligations are currently weighing down
me and ryan
and so much more if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week
that's right this uh this is our minimal
episode we
every every week we release a second
private podcast episode though
over on patreon that's one free minimal
episode
every tuesday that's the one you're
listening to right now and
then we have the maximal episode every
thursday
which is for the non-free loaders
it's for the truly committed the ones
who desire that's right
yeah that's why you judge the freeloader
that's right
it's just the truth it's just the truth
we love all of you uh yes yes indeed and
we don't expect you to support us
to be part of the five percent who do
but if you'd like to and you'd like a
whole lot more
of less well then every thursday we do a
long form a maximal episode so visit
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe you'll get a
personal link so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app it's
cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps this show 100 advertisement
free
plus if you are one of the our uh
maximal episode subscribers over there
patreon supporters
you also have a whole back catalog of of
archives there's like hundreds of hours
of previous private podcast episodes
it's the only place you can listen to
you mentioned the biggest failures oh
yeah we have a the biggest failure
segment that catalog of that
yeah yeah there's there's a bunch of
episodes of that so we record a biggest
failure segment with all of our guests
after the fact
after after the podcast and and so they
talk about things they've have failed at
and the lessons they've learned from
that also we do ask the minimalist
anything
every every month on patreon and when we
do live events all of our previous live
events
are on patreon as well and any future
live events
are only on patreon so you can find that
the minimalists.com
support to subscribe get your personal
link so that plays in your favorite
podcast app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hey guys so my name is sam and i just
wanted to share my favorite
minimalism tip which involves ryder
carroll's bullet journal method
which is kind of a way of journaling
that incorporates an agenda with a to-do
list with
just like a regular journal that you
would keep day to day and
it's been great because it's actually
kind of allowed me to declutter my space
a lot more
i've gotten rid of a lot of sticky notes
that i used to keep everywhere with
reminders all the time
i used to have different books where i'd
keep track of for example my schedule
for the day
and that's all now in one place which
has been great
but um another thing is that i've kind
of modified the method as well to kind
of suit my own lifestyle a little bit
more
and so now every day i make a page in my
journal
where i keep track of firstly you know
my appointments my to-do list my
schedule for the day but i also have a
section in there for
keeping track of what my favorite part
of the day was my mood throughout the
day
and there's also a section in there for
notes
and that is where i write down kind of
everything i've
done that day and just kind of quick
like bullet point form
i also might put in a few pictures if i
you know felt so inclined so it's kind
of like evolved to
merge with a scrapbook almost and doing
that has had kind of an unexpected side
effect of
i feel less inclined to hang on to
sentimental items
because honestly like at the beginning
of every year i've just started doing a
page
where i put all the pictures of my
highlights from the previous year
and so doing that that allows me to get
rid of a lot of things that i was
holding on to that i didn't really want
to hold on to but i kind of was hung up
about getting rid of it
um nowadays i just can you know flip
back through my
bullet journal pages and i can see all
of these
beautiful you know memories that i had
and i don't really have to associate
those memories with objects anymore
necessarily
um and a great thing about that as well
is that
if i run into an item that i want to get
rid of and you know i don't want to hold
on to it anymore but i'm hung up about
getting rid of it because it's
sentimental and i feel like i
should keep it out of some kind of
obligation um
honestly i just take a picture of it and
stick it in the journal
and for me that seems to do the trick
where i just kind of like
the switch flips in my brain and it's
like the part of my brain that wanted to
hang onto it is satisfied so
i might stick it in my journal and then
maybe write down a couple of bullet
points about you know the memories i had
that are associated with the object and
all of that
and it's been great because when i flip
back through my
journals to kind of reference maybe a
recipe that i
liked a few years ago or maybe the notes
that i had on a project i worked on
i'm able to kind of flip past and see
all of these pictures and
you know notes on all these objects as
well so i'm actually
kind of appreciating them more now that
they're gone
hi my name is stephanie i am from
toronto ontario canada and i wanted to
just um
share a tool that has really been added
value to my life as somebody who is
going through grad school wanting to do
a phd and does need to kind of refer
back to those uh those items and those
notes uh evernote is really great
because you can actually
scan scanning party uh scan all your
items and chapters from
books uh you know journal articles your
notes et cetera et cetera
and you can import them into evernote
and you can actually
tag them and you can
collaborate and share your notebooks
with uh colleagues and stuff and
what this does is like if you want to go
back in
time and review kind of uh like
something
you know that you need to reference you
can go right to your tags and all your
items that are under that particular
category
will show up and you can show all your
notes you can add to it you can
collaborate
it's just a fantastic tool if you want
to move from keeping all those books and
keeping
all those references those reference
sheets with loose papers
to a digital form it's added a lot of
value to my life and i'm just sharing it
with everybody else
all right y'all that's almost it for us
for added value this week
i want to play a song from the
soundtrack of less is now
yeah so ryan this is the second time
we've worked with
we they did it again it's spelled vve
now here's the weird thing drew and
nate they formed this band just to make
our first documentary soundtrack
and they came back together they bought
they brought other people in to write
and and produce and i mean uh so drew is
a grammy award i'm sorry
nate is a grammy award-winning winning
producer and he is a phenomenal talent
drew
has a voice of an angel it's like an
instrument
and they are from utah they brought in
all these other musicians to make this
gorgeous gorgeous soundtrack for les is
now
and the opening track actually closes
the documentary
it's a song called glorious and ryan i
don't know if you know the story behind
this
uh scott uh one of the guys they work
with wrote
a lot of the lyrics to it uh him and
drew and and
and scott when we were in no no scott
shepard i believe his name is he's in a
band called uh book
on tape book up worm on tape broken book
on tapeworm
uh yeah anyway it's phenomenal his music
he's one of the best like um uh
just song writers that
no one has had the pleasure of listening
to so you're going to get to listen to
at the end of this episode because
this song glorious by the whole
soundtrack is beautiful yeah you can
find it
uh by the way we don't own the rights of
this music it's not ours we just
license it from them for the film
although they created it
all original just for the film now this
song
the the backstory behind is they they
watch the initial cut of the film
and they sort of incorporated my
childhood story the boxes under the bed
with drew's own you know childhood story
as well and i'm sure some of scott's
base story got in there nate's story got
in there
but it's just about the insecurities of
growing up and and how we think we need
to communicate
love through things and when we do that
we really lose sight
of real love and so that song is called
glorious we'll play you out today
with that also some of you have been
asking for behind the scenes footage
from les
is now i think we're gonna do that on
patreon
uh and so in the coming months i've been
talking to matt about this
i don't know when we're gonna do it but
ryan you had a phenomenal scene that we
just didn't make the film yeah but with
the drug abuse and the bar
fight scene and doc green beating you up
yeah you had a black eye and then of
course extended interviews so
for each of these people who are in the
film like irwin and annie and and
uh danae and tk and
um dave ramsey everyone who's in the
film
we spent over an hour with each of them
i think we could use parts of those
interviews as well
so we'll probably do that over on
patreon also
how many of you are taking the less is
now challenge this month some of you
probably know
of it as the 30-day minimalism game we
finished the the documentary lessons now
with the the less is now challenged and
ryan i don't know about you but i've
seen
so so so many people posted photos of
what they're letting go of and in fact
if you want to see what
my family is we were we're challenged to
do it again i don't know how we're going
to get rid of 496 items this month ryan
yeah
but ella ella's toys she's not going to
have any
[Laughter]
uh but if you want to see our journey
you can follow my wife
rebecca it's at minimalwellness on
instagram she's posting a photo every
day of
what we are getting rid of during this
30 day less is now
challenge go ahead and post yours with
the hashtag less is now
uh real quick right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
ryan our book trailer just came out
jordan did a i mean he is a genius
i mean oh my the growth we've seen from
jordan of the last year and a half
this book trailer is like i've seen him
do some amazing things it might be the
best thing i've seen him do it
is phenomenal we went all over los
angeles to
film this thing uh the book is called
love people use things if you pre-order
it before january 31st we have this like
this uh this bundle the love people use
things bundle this
is a bumper sticker ryan so you can take
our message with you wherever you go did
you
do you have one of those on your car i
don't have bumper stickers
but for those of you like bumper
stickers yeah bookmark's awesome mariah
uh
she uses i brought one of those home and
she stole it from me did she yeah all
right so yeah you get the love people
use things
dibs on the mark as well you can have it
and then
ryan the computer sticker so you don't
have to have a logo on your computer
anymore your dell or your apple
oh it says love people use a thing i'm
gonna put one of those for you i'm gonna
put that bumper sticker i'm gonna use
all these actually i'm gonna put this
on my because all i have is like a i
voted sticker covering up my mac
thing this is much better um and i'm
gonna put that bumper sticker on the
on my long board dude it's funny every
time i get that
long board out because there's just like
it's it's a lot of backstage
um stickers that we got right from
different venues yeah different venues
not to mention
some people's art and shop yeah but it's
funny i was like looking at the
longboard the other
day um i could talk about it for i could
for three hours i could tell you stories
off of that longboard right and it feels
yeah it's pretty
cool it was a conversation starter it's
like it's like kindling in a way
but if it's spontaneously combusted i
mean i wouldn't be happy
about it but you know i wouldn't
completely miss it
yeah yeah you don't feel obligated to
hold on to it i actually took a picture
of it because
it's really nice to be reminded of all
those stories so
you know let's say did i lost it or got
stolen i could always go to that picture
and still look at those different
stickers and
go on for three hours about every you
know all the stories right
yeah and by the way you don't if you
lost the the stickers you don't lose the
stories
that's absolutely that's the message
that we continue to convey
i think jordan you can see that a lot of
people use things as back there on that
shelf in the back you can see it on
camera if you're watching on youtube
it's our new book it's called love
people use things if you'd like to see
the trailer and also see the backstory
behind the title
head on over to lovepeopleusethings.net
we're retro and cool so we use the
dotnet
and that's not because the other the dot
com was not available
and someone's squatting on it and
extorting us for over a thousand dollars
no dude the dot
honestly i actually like dot nets better
than dot com there you go love people
use things.net
also you get it a lot of people use
things wallpaper for your smartphone
and for your computer so you can have
that message with you wherever you go
including the bookmart bookmark the
computer sticker the bumper sticker
if you pre-order the book before january
31st
2021 then you will get that whole
pack included now you're autographing
every single
bookmark right with invisible ink
[Laughter]
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
you can come to one of our live podcast
shows visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com we'll never
send you spam or junk or advertisements
but we will also send you
our simple sunday emails whenever we
send those so any
new writings from the minimalists those
will show right up in your inbox
never any junk though if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it